JIM LECINSKI: Well,
good afternoon.
My name is Jim Lecinski.
I'm a vice president of
sales here at Google.
And I'd like to
welcome you to the
second of our ongoing
series of discussions--
Race at Google, a
discussion, an exploration,
and an ongoing dialogue about
racial justice, social justice,
diversity, and inclusion issues.
We're originating to you
here today from our office
in Chicago, at Google
Chicago, one of the epicenter
cities of our country,
where all of these issues
are coming to a head
and in the news and full
of current events.
And so it's especially important
and especially poignant
that we have this discussion
originating from Chicago
to the rest of the Google
offices and around the world
here today.
And so we have a
very lively panel--
a VIP, blue ribbon group--
to explore these issues.
I'd like to get things
started by introducing
your host for the day, our
diversity business partner
leader here at Google
Dr. Myosha McAfee.
Welcome.
MYOSHA MCAFEE: Well,
hello, Chi-Town.
I have only been cool for about
four months, and oddly enough,
as of last week, I am no longer
a diversity business partner.
I currently don't have a title.
But I'm going to
want to make one up,
because that's Google
style on some level, right?
Like, we'll switch
you up, and we'll
figure out the details later.
So I'm the in-house race expert.
I do a lot of our strategy
for race at Google.
So how are we going
to be developing
our skills around this?
How are we going
to be developing
our muscles around this?
I'm going to be in charge of
creating the strategy for that
and the programming for it.
So we are now at
Revolutionary Change-- The
Role of the Disruptor.
So when I think about the
word disruptor, most of us,
when we applied to Google, heard
a story of, this is a company
of innovators. .
This is a company of disruptors.
There's people who are all
about making change, right?
So we wanted to zoom in
on that particular role,
that particular
archetype, and think
about what is the
role of the disruptor
in-house when we're talking
about race, specifically.
So a topic that most of us
feel a lot of anxiety about,
most of us don't have a huge
expanse of knowledge around,
but we're paying attention to
what's happening in the world.
We're paying attention
after Philando,
after Alton, after a whole slew
of African-Americans, Latinos
Native Americans, that
are top three groups
killed by police officers.
We're uncomfortable with
killed by police officers
terminology, because some of
us have cops as family members.
Some of us grew up
trusting the police.
We actually experience them
as folks who serve and protect
the community.
So it kind of created
a climate internally,
and I think also externally,
and on the national stage,
of how do we navigate
this conversation?
How do we begin to have it?
And so part of what we want
to do in the educating process
is to have race series
at the very beginning,
where we're inviting
experts, people
who feel comfortable having
these conversations, people who
feel comfortable
disagreeing, people who feel
comfortable stepping over
that red line and getting bit
or catching a blowback,
or whatever it is.
So we thought it
would be a great idea
to have those people
be on the stage today
to kind of model for us
what that looks like,
so we know, oh, I can actually
enter this conversation
and not have to worry about not
waking up tomorrow-- most of us
feel the fear that intensely,
like, will I wake up tomorrow
if I say something
in this moment--
and to also just bear
witness of the fact
that people can
disagree with each other
and still be a productive
dialogue, right?
And I can be in the
role of a disruptor.
I can catch some heat
from being a disruptor
and still have a
job tomorrow, still
have colleagues who
like me tomorrow, right?
So that's what we wanted
to model here on the stage.
To begin, Roland Martin is
going to be our moderator.
And Roland is a commentator
for TV 1 cable network
and host of "Washington
Watch" with Roland Martin.
You've also probably
seen him on CNN.
He appeared on a variety
of the network's shows.
He's also a national
award winning
and multifaceted journalist.
His latest book, "The First--
President Barack Obama's Road
to the White House, as a
recently reported by Roland S,
Martin," will be available
outside the door.
Please join me in
welcoming Roland Martin.
ROLAND MARTIN: Y'all good?
MYOSHA MCAFEE: I'm good.
ROLAND MARTIN:
In-house race expert.
All your black questions--
let's go see her.
Hi, glad to be here.
That's a slightly old bio.
I'm host and managing
editor of "News One Now,"
which is a daily
morning show on TV One.
And it's the first
morning show in history
that specifically
targets African-Americans
with our show.
We're the second largest black
cable network in the country.
And so we deal with these
topics every single day,
five days a week.
So I'm certainly
happy to be here
to share this conversation,
internally, externally,
and certainly when we're able
to stream this live to folks
outside of here.
So let's get right to it.
Introducing our
panel-- first up,
my homeboy, he knew
he was in Chicago,
so he wore his bow tie as an
ode to Louis Farrakhan, Nation
of Islam.
He probably going to
leave here with a bean pie
to go back to Connecticut--
Dr. Steve Perry,
a national education figure.
Of course, many of us know him.
He was a contributor on CNN.
We were there together.
He also was the principal of
Capital Preparatory Magnet
School in Hartford.
100% of their students
went to four-year colleges.
Right now he is doing his own
thing with his own schools.
He has one there in Bridgeport.
They are opening one in Harlem.
And he wants to have a bunch
of them all across the country.
He's a little shy, so
put your hands together
and welcome Dr. Steve Perry.
Sit wherever you want to sit.
Don't matter.
STEVE PERRY: All right.
ROLAND MARTIN: Next
up is Carmen Perez.
You have seen her on television,
radio, online, more than likely
with her fist raised in the air.
That's what she does so she
can keep from punching people.
She is very much involved
in issues of social justice.
And it was 11 years
ago when she hooked up
with the great Harry Belafonte.
Raise your hand if you
know Harry Belafonte.
If you don't, what
is wrong with you?
He created this group called
the Gathering for Justice
with Carmen.
And of course, you
may have seen her also
work with the New York
Justice League, one
of the organizations that
falls under the Gathering
for Justice.
She's also one of
the founders of that.
And so we want to
bring up Carmen Perez.
Come on, Carmen.
She believes in branding.
So you see her Justice
League NYC shirt
CARMEN PEREZ: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: That's right.
She's always fundraising,
so I'm surprised she doesn't
have the website on there.
David Stoval, a professor
here at University
of Illinois at Chicago.
He focuses on several different
areas, including critical race
theory, as well as the
relationship between housing
and education and also
between schools and community
stakeholders.
He knew we were
coming to Google,
so he dressed up just for y'all.
Help Steve and Carmen, though.
I moderate a little
bit differently.
Everybody gets cracked on.
All right, then, and so
last, but certainly not
least, my homebody Jeff Johnson.
We go way back.
And Jeff, of course,
has been involved
in media for a number of years.
You.
May have seen him on BET,
also doing commentary
on "The Rickey Smiley Show."
He's filled in for me
on my show on TV One.
And he, of course, has his own
company, JIJ Communications.
He's the managing principal
based out of Baltimore.
And normally Jeff's
wearing bow ties,
but he knew it was
Google, so he's chilling.
Y'all can check out, he
got the funkiest socks.
On the panel.
So I want to open
this thing this way.
They gave me-- and
I appreciate it.
Y'all have some phenomenal notes
and talking points y'all gave
me.
I'm using none of them.
So I want to start
this way, because I
love to look at words.
I love to look at
how we frame things.
This is call
"Revolutionary Change-- The
Role of the Disruptor."
I want to first deal
with revolutionary.
What is it about
that word that scares
America when the revolutionary
does not look white?
That wasn't on the list
they gave me of questions.
DAVID STOVAL: Well,
I mean, I think
the first thing that happens is
when the revolutionary does not
look white, i.e. it is not
George Washington, Thomas
Jefferson, or whoever
else we lie about,
it actually is going to ask a
different question of the place
that we live in.
It's going to ask us now a
deeper question of indictment.
What has happened?
And then, our inability to
talk about these things that
are actually happening in the
way that they're happening now
makes it more difficult
for us to even envision
a revolutionary changing
the conditions of the most
oppressed.
JEFF JOHNSON: Let me dive in
a little bit, because I think
in simple terms, what's
scary is the vision
of the revolutionary.
And so revolution is about
how do you tear something down
for the purpose of
building something else?
And what scares people
about black revolutionaries
has been the vision of
what they want to tear down
and the vision they
want to create,
because we're
talking about power.
So the fear is not necessarily
about I like Thomas Jefferson
over Nat Turner.
It's what is Nat Turner
attempting to tear down?
And what is the vision of
what needs to be created.
That scares people,
because they inherently
believe that in order
for those people
to have any semblance
of power, I lose mine.
ROLAND MARTIN: The
reason I pose that--
I'm going to jump in--
is because this is James
Forman's book. .
James Forman was one
of the organizers
of Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee, one
of their leaders.
And this book is
titled "The Making
of Black Revolutionaries."
One of the greatest
organizers, Steve and Carmen,
and what's
interesting about that
is that you look
at what SNCC did,
the changes that took
place between 1960 and '68,
we credit Dr. King.
We credit NAACP,
National Urban League.
But SNCC forced a lot of
that change-- Freedom Summer.
We can go through all
the different examples
that they did, because he
understood, to Jeff's point,
this is about tearing
something down and creating
something different.
STEVE PERRY: First of
all, one of things I do
want to acknowledge, and why
I'm deeply humbled and honored
to be here-- the fact that
there are three men up here
and not more women,
I think is worth
noting when we're having a
conversation around disruption,
especially as it relates to
the African-American community.
The male perspective
has been overstated.
So we could all do a
better job of that.
So there's that.
The second thing is,
I think that in order
for some white people to see
some African-Americans deciding
that it's time for
a revolution, they
have to accept that that which
they have become comfortable
with is in fact a problem.
If more people,
regardless of hue,
began to look at, let's
say just Chicago, and say,
this is really messed up.
They'd have to acknowledge
that on some level,
they're complicit
in their silence
and at another level that by
maintaining the status quo,
they essentially
push the knife deeper
into the back of the
African-American community.
So until such time
as individuals
decide that they wish
to disrupt the system,
they have to accept
or allow themselves
to be lulled into sleep
that the system isn't bad,
and that we actually
want it this way.
So when we start
saying, actually, I
don't want to this way.
I'd like it kind of
like you have it,
where you don't worry about
police officers pulling you
over, or you don't
have to worry,
as I did when my children
played in our own neighborhood,
that one of my own
neighbors was going
to say that they
were carrying a gun
and that four squad cars would
come after my 11-year-old
on the night of
his 11th birthday.
I'd like it like
you have it, where
you can have your kids play in
your neighborhood without fear.
When some white
people begin to awaken
to the depth of the
reality of the pain
that it is to be
African-American
in this country,
they're going to have
to do something about it.
They're going to have to
do something about it.
ROLAND MARTIN: Carmen.
CARMEN PEREZ: And
so I want everybody
to put your hands out.
Put them together.
Right, that's easy.
Now try doing it
the opposite way.
Try doing it to where
it's uncomfortable.
And I always tell
people, if you are
comfortable with seeing black
and brown people oppressed,
you are part of the problem.
And I don't know
anybody's story here.
And I'm not going to say,
oh, I can relate to you,
and we've been down
this path or whatever.
But I do know that
when something
impacts your community,
you want to change it.
And so we're all up here
because there's something
that happened in our lives.
I'm making assumptions
now up here,
but there's something that
happened in our lives that
told us no more.
Enough is enough.
Whether you grew up in a
community that was plagued
by violence, whether you
witnessed your brother hog
tied, whether you had a sister
[INAUDIBLE]-- whatever it was,
there was something that
then changed the trajectory
of your life to
be a change agent.
And so it's the fact that
when I walk down the street,
I could see somebody
being handcuffed,
and that person looks like me.
It's the fact that when
I walk into a prison,
and I walk into a detention
center, the young women
that I'm serving look like me.
It's the fact that I
could walk into Google,
and I don't really see
anybody that looks like me. .
So it's a larger question
about you digging deeper, going
into the cavern of your heart,
and asking, what can I do?
Because it shouldn't be
about you feeling my pain.
It should be about the fact
that we all, like you said,
brother, want to be able
to walk down the street.
I want to be able to
walk downtown Chicago
and not feel like I'm in a
community that is gentrified,
because the only people
that I was walking down
the street that looked like me
were the servers or the host.
I want to be able to have
children and tell them
they could be anything--
anything in the world.
I want to be able to have
the type of lifestyle
that I've seen around
other colleagues, right?
That's all I want.
And so I work hard
every single day.
And I'm involved in the
Black Lives Matter movement,
and people are like,
well, you're Latina.
Why do you care?
And I'm like, because
I had black teachers.
I had black coaches.
And I had black pastors.
I've traveled the world.
I've been to Cuba.
I've been to all these places.
And I've seen that
black people are
oppressed all over the world.
You don't need to come to a
race conversation to see that.
You see it every single day
when you turn on turn on CNN,
or you turn on Fox,
whatever people prefer.
You see it every
single day, right?
And so I know that once
black people are free,
my people are free.
ROLAND MARTIN: The thing
I think is interesting
when you talk about seeing--
I've lived and worked
in Chicago for six years.
And what many of you here
in this room, whether you're
black, white, Hispanic--
doesn't matter
who you are-- you may not
realize that in this city, when
they have the tourist
maps of Chicago,
it did not extend
past 22nd Street.
DAVID STOVAL: Trust.
ROLAND MARTIN: It didn't
go into Bronzeville.
It did not literally
go past 22nd Street.
So what that said in Chicago--
if you come to Chicago,
we only want you to
go from here to here.
And it's amazing
how a lot of people,
again, don't have the
context to understand
a city like this
here-- Jeff, I want
you to speak to this-- also
have and understand the history.
And I want to use
Chicago as the example.
Harold Washington runs
for mayor in 1983,
and the racial
hatred that existed
that a sitting member of
Congress who was black
would dare run to
be mayor of a city
with the second-largest
concentration
of black people outside
the continent of Africa.
JEFF JOHNSON: So
what's the question?
ROLAND MARTIN:
Question is, I want
you to speak to that
experience and how
folks who might live
here present day
doesn't realize that,
oh yeah, that was 1983,
but it still lives and permeates
the city and its structure
today.
JEFF JOHNSON: Well, I think
one, any time marginalized
people have the gumption
to lead not just those that
are marginalized,
but everybody, there
are two things that happens.
Number one, it
says, oh my god, we
don't want them in control
of the purse strings.
And let's be honest,
because I think
when we have this race
conversation, a lot Of times we
have it through the lens of we
as marginalized people are only
talking to white people.
There's multi-level
conversations
that need to be happening here.
And so even we have
these conversations
about black political
power, black political power
has never been about
black political positions.
And so when you think about what
happened in Chicago, similar
to what happened in Atlanta,
similar to what happened in DC,
these mayors were powerful, not
just because they were black
and they were able to
get control of City Hall.
They were powerful because
they shifted the very resources
of the city to create
black millionaires,
to create opportunity,
to create power.
And while they didn't give it
to everybody-- let's be clear.
Everybody didn't get it--
there was a shift of power
that scared people.
And so whether it was
Maynard Jackson in Atlanta,
or whether it was Marion
Barry in Washington DC,
or whether it was the first
black mayor in Cleveland, Ohio,
with Carl Stokes,
the fear was not just
about the gumption of thinking
that you could have power.
It was what ultimately happens
when this individual has
the ability to shift wealth
and to shift resources
and to shift what
communities look like?
And to Carmen's point,
the real challenge
is because so many
of these cities
have been designed with
disenfranchisement in mind,
folks that were never a part
of those other communities
have never been able to
see the inherent value
in broad-based
economic development.
So I live in a
city like Baltimore
that I think has had decades of
intentional lack of development
in certain parts of
the city that are
primarily black and poor white.
And Baltimore has billions
of dollars in development.
The harbor looks fantastic.
The communities that extend
from the harbor look amazing.
People come to Baltimore,
and they love it.
They get to go
down to the water.
They get to get some crabs.
They have a great
time at hotels.
They shop.
But you have block upon
block upon block upon block
upon block of some of the
worst blight in America,
and not under 1 mayor,
or 2 mayors, or 3 mayors,
or 4 mayors-- of 10 mayors.
That doesn't happen by accident.
And so the challenge is
for those people of color
or marginalized people
that get into power--
the disruption is not
you being elected.
The disruption is, do you
do something different
when you are there
to shift power
in a way that creates
disruption versus you giving
the appearance of
disruption by you being
the first, second, or third
person of color that's
in this position?
ROLAND MARTIN: And that's
what I wanted to go to Jeff,
because I want--
and anyone can jump
in on this one, because when
we talk about revolution
and disruption, what we are
facing right now in 2016,
this is a battle over power.
And this is a generation
that has seen--
that's post-civil rights.
They saw integration.
They saw Dr. King,
Fanny Lou Hamer.
They saw so many others.
And they said, no.
We don't want equality.
We want power.
CARMEN PEREZ: And just
to kind of go back
to what you were saying
in regards to SNCC,
they organized.
They were able to accomplish
so many victories.
But when you look
at the victory,
right, gaining the
opportunity to integrate,
you were integrating
what Mr Belafonte
talks about-- his last
conversation with Dr. King was.
They were integrating
into a burning house.
So Dr. King then says, so
then, what do we become?
And he says, fireman.
But at the end of
the day you're,
integrating institutions
that were racist.
So nobody woke up the
next day and said,
hey, we're walking being black
children into our schools.
Look at how what happened
with the Little Rock Nine.
And so for me, I always
ask Mr Belafonte,
what was the integration plan?
So you made the
assumption that there
was no more racism in
America after that went away.
However, there was no
real integration plan.
And these institutions
are still racist.
JEFF JOHNSON: But that
was never the plan.
CARMEN PEREZ: Right.
JEFF JOHNSON: But
I think there's
a misnomer when we talk about
civil rights and social justice
of the 60s.
The plan was never integration.
It was desegregation.
And so there was
this myth that it
was about black
folks and white folks
and poor people
and wealthy people
holding hands and
singing "Kumbaya"
and all feeling
good about living
in the same community, when
it was really about how do you
dismantle policy and
legislation that prevents people
from maximizing access to
the resources that give them
the ability to have the
pursuit of happiness?
But this narrative about that
integration piece I think
has persisted because it allows
other generations to say,
wait a minute.
I was never supposed to
be about power for you.
It was supposed to
be about you being
able to get along in spaces
of other people's power.
And when you're allowed to have
that integration narrative that
continues, the
marginalized always
feel comfortable
being marginalized,
and white supremacy
is able to persist,
because it gives white folks
the gumption to believe,
wait a minute.
Integration was always
about these people
coming in and being a part of
what we created and gave them
access to.
Hell no.
That's not what it's about.
It was about desegregation
to change policies and access
to the very resources
that create power.
And that's scary.
And I'm sorry.
Not just to white folks--
there are black folks
that were scared of
that, because of how
they had been conditioned.
ROLAND MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE].
JEFF JOHNSON: And because of
how they had been conditioned.
And I'm not disagreeing
with Carmen.
I'm saying that the
narrative of integration
has persisted as the goal of
what civil rights was about.
And that was never the goal. .
STEVE PERRY: In the space
within which I work,
which is education,
I often found myself
fighting people to
get them to understand
that African-American
children are
as bright as any other
children on Earth.
They were born no differently,
no different process
to make them.
We all happen the same way.
The difference is
that when we come out
into a system that
was not designed
to support our overall growth,
we fall short of the beauty
that we have inside of us.
And so when Jeff is talking
about the disruption
of systems, what
that, for me, means
is the disruption of a system
that educates children or sends
children to schools
that are closest
to their house, addresses that
were determined by keeping
certain people away
from other people,
by systems that were
determined to ensure
that those children who
live in that neighborhood
will never gain the same access
to the quality of education
that's required to participate
fully in the economy,
to know to read,
to know to write,
to have the basic self-esteem
to be able to sit in a room.
Many of my kids won't
ask a question, for fear
that they will
think that someone
thinks that they're stupid.
It's breaking down
those barriers.
Or worse still, that
they will answer those
questions and people will call
them white-- in either case,
they will somehow be
chastised for exploring
the beauty that's inside them.
But this system
that is put in place
is not just some esoteric
notion of systems
that we often get caught up in.
But it's an actual set of
principles that ensures that
that which occurred in Baltimore
will continue to occur over
and over and over again,
regardless of the color
of the person that
you put in place,
until such time as people of all
colors get sick and tired of it
and say, man, this just
can't be America. .
We can't be this place
that promises a child
failure for the
rest of the life,
imprisons them for failing if
they only just did what they
were supposed to do, which
was to go to the school that
was never going to educate
them, and Blame the parents
or anyone else.
It stops those individuals
who seek to give them freedom.
I'll say the final part here.
The most revolutionary thing
you can do, Brother Roland,
is teach people who were
never supposed to be taught,
to show them that there is
nothing wrong with them,
to show them that they
are beautiful and capable,
to give them the
access to the wisdom,
because the root of every
revolution is education. .
And this is why it was one of
the laws on the slave books
that said very clearly it
was punishable by death.
Teach a slave to read,
and we will kill your ass.
DAVID STOVALL:
There's a part here
that I think we want to
kick this up a little bit,
because I appreciate
everybody's point.
And it's staying around looking
at desegregation, integration,
and what you talk about power. .
We should kick that
up a bit, because what
we're talking about is equity.
But there is a piece in equity.
Equity says that
some people who have
been further disenfranchised
might need more.
And herein lies the
problem, because remember
when Harold Washington
was elected, after 1987,
they changed the voting laws.
So here in Chicago, to
win a mayoral election,
you have to win 50% plus 1.
ROLAND MARTIN: Where
the previous law
was whoever gets the top vote--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROLAND MARTIN: So
when he ran, there
were three people-- him,
Jane Byrne, the incumbent,
and Richard Daley, who
was States Attorney.
He comes in first.
Then a Democrat
running as a Republican
in November,
Washington barely wins,
because it was white black.
But yes, the moment he died,
they changed the law and said,
we will not have this
repeating itself.
And you have not had a black
mayor in Chicago since.
DAVID STOVALL: And you have not
had voter registration or voter
turnout over 35%.
So now if we think about
that particular relationship,
Harold Washington was clear,
and he was pragmatic in it.
He talked about equity, right?
So Harold Washington was
one of the first folks
to talk about
affordable housing.
So Harold Washington
had on the books,
if there was any unit have
built over six units--
so that's any
apartment building that
had over six apartments
in it-- three of them
had to be affordable housing.
So now we're struggling in
Chicago for affordable housing
legislation at 20%.
So now, in thinking about
this equity, equity is saying,
no, you need what you
need when you need it.
That might mean that folks
who have historically
been disenfranchised
might need a little more
in the larger equation.
And herein lies the
question of power.
That's why random
dude with the comb
over can talk all this
crazy shit, right?
That's why he can say
these things, because he
can get folks to believe that
you now have lost something
that you never really had.
You vote against
your own interest,
because if these folks get in
power, this is going to happen.
Remember the advertisement
where Harold Washington when
Bernard Epton ran against him.
It was Bernard Epton or else.
Donald Trump is sitting in
front of folks and saying,
look, you better rock
with me, or else.
They coming for you, right?
This garbage last week--
what do you have to lose?
58% of your folks
are in poverty--
whatever bullshit he
was talking about it--
and then saying me a chance.
What?
Because this thing
around now-- we
have to be able to
ask a deeper question,
because on top of equity,
we also need to understand--
and everybody talked about
this-- white supremacy
is not a group of white
extremists calling people
the N-word or lynching folks.
White supremacy is the
understood views and values
of Western European-descended
able-bodied heterosexual
Christian men as normal
right and good. .
Everyone else is deserving
of gratuitous punishment
until they acquiesce to those
purported views and values.
ROLAND MARTIN: Interesting.
Steve, you made a
point that I want
to come back to when you
talk about it in the law,
slaves couldn't read, because
when I hear people say,
can you all just call it
Black Lives Matter Too?
Can you just put the too on
the end so I feel comfortable?
Straight up, that's real.
As you were talking, I begin
to think about the fact--
and then when Carmen said
being Latina involved in this
movement-- if you actually
look at American history,
not his-story-- some of you
going to catch that when you
get [INAUDIBLE]-- black folks
have always tried to force
America to live up to
its written ideals.
There's a white
woman sitting in here
right now that denies
the reality that they
have benefited from Affirmative
Action more than anybody else.
Title IX is talked about
as being about sports,
when in fact, Title
IX was about opening
the professional schools to be
professors, doctors, dentists,
lawyers.
Title IX is a provision of
the Civil Rights Act of 1964.
Anybody here disabled?
The Americans With
Disabilities Act
is a provision of
the Civil Rights Act.
If you are Vietnamese,
and you go vote,
your ballot is in Vietnamese.
That's because of the
Voting Rights Act, 1965.
If you are gay and
lesbian, and you
are excited you can
now get married,
the equal protection clause
comes from the amendment
black folks fought.
You're in education.
Public finance
education in the South
was a result of free slaves
putting it in the Constitution.
So my point there--
black folks have always
fought for laws that everybody
in America has benefited from.
CARMEN PEREZ: That's right.
ROLAND MARTIN: So make the
point to folks who say,
but I don't have a place
in Black Lives Matter, when
if you change the laws
dealing with the cops,
it helps you too.
STEVE PERRY: Well, you
know, it was David Walker,
in David Walker's Appeal, who
talked about the condition
of slavery being the worst.
ROLAND MARTIN: Some say Latino.
You say Chicano.
There's a distinction.
CARMEN PEREZ: So
Hispanic is a term
that was given to us
by the government,
and I don't
originate from Spain.
My people, who are Mexican,
are actually a rapeage.
So we didn't have this love
story about sitting on a panel,
we fell in love.
I don't know.
But we are a rapeage of people.
However, in 1843, there was
the Treaty of Guadalupe.
So there is Chicanos.
There is Mexicanos that
were born in the Americas,
in North America.
So my father is 92 years old.
My great-grandparents
are from Texas.
My great-great-grandparents
And so when the
US ended up taking
over Texas and California,
my great-grandparents
became American citizens.
Unfortunately,
they were no longer
being able to keep their land.
So we are Chicanos because
we are a landless people.
But we are so very political.
We are politicized individuals.
The reason why there
are so many, I think,
Chicanos that can relate to the
African-American struggle-- I'm
not saying that we came
enslaved-- is the fact that we
are also incarcerated
at very large rates,
as African-Americans.
And so there's a difference
between a Mexicano
who just came to America
and has no connection
to the history here.
So for me, it's about learning
about Booker T. Washington,
learning about Marcus Garvey,
all these individuals.
And so what I will
say, it's history.
It's the lack of education.
It's the fact that
a lot of individuals
don't know the struggles.
Particularly in the
Latino community,
and maybe even in
the white community,
there's no connection to history
here in the United States.
ROLAND MARTIN: And I want
you to make a distinction
because the part
of this discussion
when we talk about race--
when you say black,
we're talking Alabama,
Mississippi, Georgia, Arkansas,
Texas, the Southern states.
That's what we're talking about.
But when we talk about--
and I say Hispanic/Latino
for a reason-- you're
talking about Cuban influence
in Florida.
You're talking about
Dominican influence
and Puerto Rican influence in
New York, Chicanos in Texas,
California You're dealing
there with nationality,
as opposed to just this
group that is in America.
That changes the discussion
when it comes to what
are people fighting for.
Go ahead.
CARMEN PEREZ: Right.
And so for me, I
always say I want
to remove the word Hispanic
from the census, because we
don't come from Spain.
Latino America,
you could say you
could swallow a little bit more.
I say I'm Latina.
If I really want to have
people understand who I am,
I say I'm Chicana.
And people will be like,
are you from Chicago?
No, I'm not from Chicago.
I'm Chicano.
ROLAND MARTIN: And most
people will actually
think Chicana means, oh,
you Latino from Chicago.
CARMEN PEREZ: Yes.
They actually do.
But certainly, I think there's
this disconnection right?
And we've got to,
again, understand
who we're dealing with.
When.
I'm talking about
black liberation,
I'm also looking at there are
1.9 Afro-Mexicanos in Mexico.
There's an erasure of
blackness in Latin America.
There's white-washing that
happens every single day when
you turn on the telenovella,
and you see white people.
And the only people
that are people of color
are the servants or the maids.
And so I constantly talk
about this in regards
to my own people,
in the sense of we
are taught to glorify whiteness.
We are taught at
a very young age
that being moreno,
that being black,
is something not to be proud of.
And there's shade-ism
that happens in Latin
America every single day.
And so for me, it's about
understanding that in my blood,
there's African;
there's indigenous,
and there's European blood.
But the European blood
isn't because-- we
didn't have this love fest.
There was wars. .
There was the conquistadors--
Hernan Cortez--
that came to Mexico
with black slaves,
with black people that
he then made into slaves.
And and so for me, when we
talk about Black Lives Matter,
again, it is about power. .
It's.
About building collective power.
There are leaders all
over this country.
We don't have just the
Malcolm Xs or the Dr. Kings.
It's a leaderful movement.
But what we want is
liberation for our people,
and we know that those currently
right now that are being
oppressed are black people.
And once Black Lives Matter,
then all lives matter.
ROLAND MARTIN: Dr.
Stovall, you earlier talked
about issue of power.
It's very interesting when
I listen to Jesse Williams
speak at the BET Awards.
And when we
mentioned freedom, he
said that freedom is
somehow conditional here.
She-- meaning Sandra
Bland-- would be alive
if she hadn't acted so free.
It's interesting to
me when I go back--
Jeff you and I have had this
conversation as well-- I
go back, when I look at
more than three speeches Dr.
King gave.
If you look at the
three books he actually
wrote-- numerous speeches--
he rarely ever used
the word equality.
He always spoke of freedom. .
What's the difference?
DAVID STOVALL: So I mean I think
when we talk about freedom,
and this is an equality, and
this is the thing, right?
So excuse this academic
thing happening.
ROLAND MARTIN: You
are an academic.
DAVID STOVALL: Right, right,
right, so they say, right?
Existential philosophers
say that anytime
you have a conversation
of equality,
the assumption is that things
are never equal, right?
And what that means is
when you're saying equal,
that's actually a term that is
actually assuming something.
It is assuming that
everyone has the same things
to get the same things.
So when we talk about
an equal society,
that's not necessarily equal.
It's always who has what,
and who has the least, right?
Freedom is the capacity
to self-determine.
So when folks are talking
about their lives as mattering,
they're talking about a
call to self-determination,
a call that says
that my body is not
the receptacle for
gratuitous punishment,
that my body is not only my
own, but one that I can claim
and one that I actually
can move in the world
without persecution.
So now, this difference
between equality
is arguing that we all
need the same things.
That is the worst assumption.
Freedom says we have
to be courageous enough
to say, not only do we
need different things,
but we are willing to get
those different things
on our own terms.
And like Assata Shakur says,
freedom is something we
don't know yet-- .
we have a grand idea of.
And it is something that
we pursue relentlessly.
And in the relentless
pursuit of that freedom,
we understand that our
bodies are in front of death
all the time when
that claim is made.
ROLAND MARTIN: Jeff, you
mentioned this relentlessness.
When the remake of "Roots" was
shown on the History Channel,
that opening scene
of Kunta Kinte going
to the plantation-- he's
going, I only see three of them
and 100 of us.
How the hell are y'all
not taking them over?
It was amazing to watch it.
He was in this constant,
I'm fighting for my freedom.
I just spoke at African
Arrival Day in Virginia,
where the first slaves
came to Point Comfort, now
Fort Monroe in Virginia--
this was on Saturday--
where they recognize that.
And we have the
400th anniversary
of remembrance in three years.
But this constant
fight for freedom,
that's the piece I don't think
a lot of Americans, including
black folks understand--
that since 1619, we
have been in this constant
fight, every step of the way,
whether it's siding
with the British
in the American Revolution,
whether it's coming out
with Emancipation Proclamation--
this constant fight
for freedom.
JEFF JOHNSON: And
I think, Roland,
even in the examples
you gave, those
are concrete examples of
institutional connection.
The fight for freedom
wasn't always about joining.
was remembering
I wasn't created for this.
So the songs that
I sing, the stories
that I tell my
children, the hope
that I give in this
ecosystem of hopelessness,
was all about
fighting for freedom.
And so, me helping you remember
your name, not the name
given to you, but the
name that you have, me
helping you remember
customs and creating customs
so that you are not
subjugated to what
they tell you can practice--
all of that was about freedom.
So you didn't have to lead a
slave revolt to be fighting
for freedom on a daily basis.
The fact that you
existed, waking up
realizing this was not
what God meant for me to be
was a push towards freedom.
I think the challenge, Roland,
as we talk about disruption,
and we haven't talked
about this yet,
is we haven't dealt with the
reality of the consequences
of disruption.
Not the consequences of
perceived disruption,
because we had a whole lot
of professional disruption
deceivers.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Especially in this city.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROLAND MARTIN: I'm
having a flashback.
JEFF JOHNSON: There are
folks on television.
There are folks in
organizations that
are paid to be
perceived as disruptors
but don't do any disrupting.
But people remember and
they know the stories--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROLAND MARTIN: See, if
this was an all-black room.
this would be
happening right now.
I messing with you.
Go ahead.
JEFF JOHNSON: So I
remember, because there
is a political side of this.
There's a social
justice side of this.
But there's also a corporate
institutional side of this.
And so I'm 43 years old and
remember the middle management
thing that corporate
America did that created
this ecosystem of black men that
could be in corporate America
just high enough not
to feel marginalized,
but not high enough
to control anything.
ROLAND MARTIN: VP of
community affairs.
STEVE PERRY: Always.
Or the Dean of Students.
JEFF JOHNSON: When I
worked for the NAACP,
we had one question we used to
ask black executives, which was
how many white
people can you fire?
I'm serious.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEFF JOHNSON: Because you
come with your big title,
and you're talking about all
these people, you can control.
ROLAND MARTIN: But do you
have P&L responsibility?
JEFF JOHNSON: But if you
can't fire no white people.
ROLAND MARTIN: There you go.
JEFF JOHNSON: I'm not even
talking about the money,
because you have black
pools of money, right?
And so you got your P&L over
your black people stuff.
But if you can't
fire no white people,
you really don't
have any importance.
ROLAND MARTIN: Don't get
scared, now, like he's
going to come fire you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEFF JOHNSON: Me and
boys used to joke
that you could tell how
long somebody's dad had been
in corporate America
by how little bass
they had left in their voice
and how little facial hair they
had.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Damn, you said bass.
JEFF JOHNSON: So there was
this piece where it was like,
you roll up into the company.
You're like, my name is Leroy.
And I'm an intern
in the mail room.
And then hey, my name is
Leroy, and I'm an intern
in the finance department.
Hello, my name is Leroy, and
I'm the CFO of this corporation.
And we laugh.
But I saw the emasculation of
black men in corporate America
in the name of being
safe enough not
to make other people
uncomfortable about the power
that they brought just
by being black men.
And the challenge that
I have is even now
we don't talk about the
consequence of disruption.
So we create the
perception of disruption
to make people feel like we're
really pissed off about stuff
that we're not pissed off
about, because we're not really
creating the
disruption, because even
those that want
to see the change
are fearful of what has
happened to the disruptors.
So whether it was Nat
Turner or whether it
was that guy that was a middle
manager in this corporation
that just got too black that
one day, and as a result,
he was minimized or
removed or fired,
or that guy that came every day
and had to cut off the goatee,
because the goatee made somebody
else feel uncomfortable,
or I dropped that
bass in my voice
because my boss don't have it
in him, and as a result of it
he's intimidated every
time I'm my authentic self,
we haven't talked
about that enough.
And so there is a generation
that, even within Black Lives
Matter-- and Carmen, tell me
if I'm wrong-- is operating off
of a perception-- not
everybody-- but too many
are operating off
perceptions of disruption.
They say, how do we create
what looks like disruption,
but hasn't created
legitimate strategy that
speaks to the dismantling
of institutions.
That is risking more than
the perception of disruption
is risking.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROLAND MARTIN: Carmen, go ahead.
But then, I'm going
back to Steve.
Go ahead.
Carmen, go ahead.
CARMEN PEREZ: Oh, I
feel, as a disruptor,
that the media perceives
certain individuals as leaders
within the Black Lives
Matter movement based
on their followers.
You don't see these
individuals in the street.
ROLAND MARTIN: Based upon
their social media followers.
CARMEN PEREZ: Social media
followers-- Twitter followers.
ROLAND MARTIN: Not
actual followers.
CARMEN PEREZ: So
these individuals
will get paid by corporations
to advertise whatever they're
advertising on their shirts
while they're getting arrested.
But I will say,
as a disruptor, we
have several individuals
within our team
in Justice League that have
different positions of power.
ROLAND MARTIN: You just threw
a gut punch at Dr. Stovall
over here.
He's like, ooh.
CARMEN PEREZ: And
we will look at how
to not only dismantle,
but infiltrate,
the systems that we're
trying to fight up against.
So if I was a disruptor
here in Google-- I'm joking.
I'm messing with y'all.
I'm messing with y'all-- but one
of the things that I was being
asked--
ROLAND MARTIN: Security.
CARMEN PEREZ: --I
was being asked
to do is I was taught to
do system accountability
from within the system.
So I learned.
I went into the criminal
justice probation department
to learn the language in order
to then come out and give
that information back
to the community,
so that we could then hold--
JEFF JOHNSON: The spook
that sat by the door.
CARMEN PEREZ: And that's the
way in which my elders have
taught me to do it.
And then there's others that
will infiltrate, but then
become that system.
And I think that's what we
were trying to figure out,
I think, sometimes, not only
in the Black Lives Matter
movement, but in every movement.
ROLAND MARTIN: It's interesting,
while I was listening to-- I'm
coming to you Steve-- Jeff
talk-- I use this phrase
a lot, parking lot militants.
That's the folks-- oh, they talk
some shit in the parking lot.
JEFF JOHNSON: E-gangsters.
ROLAND MARTIN: Oh
man, but then when
you go back in that building,
to Jeff's point, what
happened to your bass?
And so, Steve, while
he was talking,
he was talking about disrupting.
I'm literally sitting here
remembering me and you at CNN
and remembering cats telling
you to cut your hair,
because it was too
wavy, and remembering
every show would get a readout
of voicemails that people left.
In nearly every show, when I
was on Anderson Cooper's show,
Paula Zahn's show, they would
come back and say, Roland,
can you smile more?
Can you smile more, because I
was kicking folks butts so bad,
white folks watching
thought I was angry.
Bill O'Reilly acting a fool
over here, and he's passionate.
I'm passionate,
therefore, I'm angry.
And I finally said,
if I smile anymore I'm
going to be a damned mannequin.
And so when you talk
about-- to Jeff's point
about the flipside of
being a disruptor--
the reality is, you will get
to the point where they say,
all right. you know what?
He too black.
STEVE PERRY: So
there are disruptors,
and there are commentators.
And there are a lot of
people who are commentators.
They can speak the speak.
And they can present
themselves as if they
are so radical and so focused.
But asked them
ever, what have you
disrupted other than a
conversation or dinner party?
CARMEN PEREZ: That's right.
STEVE PERRY: Like, what
really have you changed?
ROLAND MARTIN: Did you ever
e-mail the CEO and push them?
STEVE PERRY: There's that.
One of the things I say,
typically, to African-Americans
who are on the come
up is live modestly,
because too many
people who I know--
they're laughing because they
know exactly what I'm talking
about-- because the day
comes when your black ass is
about to be asked to leave.
And if you care too
much about this job,
then you have to
shut your mouth.
If you think of
yourself as somebody
who sees this a job,
and the only way
that you will live or
maintain this lifestyle,
you have to be silent.
To be a disruptor, you have
to accept you will be fired.
You will be asked to leave.
It is a condition of the
condition of those of us
who feel compelled
to do something.
I get so sick and
tired of people--
god knows the
Twittersphere has made
people think they're somebody.
My sons yesterday were
taking me through all
these different people who
are somebody on the internet.
And I'm like, damn,
for putting makeup on?
You got 47 million followers
because you arch your eyebrows?
ROLAND MARTIN:
They beat, though.
STEVE PERRY: That's dope.
So the point is that there's--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEVE PERRY: --this
entire group of people
thinking that they matter.
And people who think
that they think
that they matter because they're
somehow connected to them.
But at the end of the
day, can I run my hands
across the building
that you built?
Can I go to go sit down and
talk to the children whose lives
you've actually influenced?
This is not a esoteric
policy conversation.
At some point,
there will be blood.
There will be blood.
I can tell you three weeks
ago, all four tires on my car
were slashed-- all four.
See y'all can have that other
conversation for other people,
but you're not having a
conversation about whether
or not you're going to have
an armed guard travel with you
because you dared to stand up
for children for whom nobody
else is willing to stand up for.
Everybody else is willing to
watch them go into these failed
schools and watch them
die incapable of learning,
not because they're
broken, but because people
keep convincing
them that there's
something wrong with them
because they are not white.
And so I'm telling you, you
ain't disrupting nothing
because you changed some
conversation on Twitter
so that you can find the next
white cop who did something
that you find disagreeable
or because somebody
at some college said
something-- always
somebody on a college
campus hanging something
in [INAUDIBLE].
And everybody
trips the hell out.
CARMEN PEREZ: I will
say, just to add,
I think there's a
lane for everybody.
There's a lane for everyone.
There are those that
build the institutions.
There's those that
work on policy.
There are those that are
professional protesters.
There are those
that are organizers.
And one of the things that I
recently-- a lot of the work
that we do is a
multi-pronged approach.
I work, again, for the Gathering
for Justice and Justice League
NYC.
And ever since we
started working around
the non-indictment
of Officer Daniel
Pantaleo in the
killing of Eric Garner,
you become a target,
because you're
trying to disrupt something.
ROLAND MARTIN: His point
with the tires, yeah.
CARMEN PEREZ: You
become a target.
And you get death threats.
And you don't know-- you
get told by the mayor,
you get a personal phone call
saying, you stop protesting.
We put a moratorium
on protesting, right?
And it's what you're
willing to do,
and what you're
not willing to do.
And so for me, it's
not about being silent.
It's not about-- you talk about
the children and the lives
of the people who you impact
because it's a life or death
situation, not only for
them, but for yourself.
Walking into prisons, you
get told before you walk
in, and I've been doing
this for 20 years,
we cannot negotiate your life.
You got to understand that
you may not come out here.
And what's interesting you
also have trolls, right?
How many of you all got trolls?
I've got plenty of trolls.
I'm an executive director
of an organization.
And because I don't compromise,
and I say anything that I want,
I don't get certain funding.
I don't get certain
sponsorships.
We make miracles happen
with rice and beans.
For me, it's about
relationships,
me calling Roland Martin
to come and host my gala.
He's like all right,
sister, I got you.
That's what it's about for me,
because at the end of the day,
I'm not going to
compromise, and I'm not
going to sell out the young
people that I work with.
But I will say it
comes with a price.
And sometimes that's
a deadly price.
JEFF JOHNSON:
Roland, real quick,
because I think I want to build
on what Carmen was saying.
I think that because so often
we talk about disruptors
through the lens of the
most aggressive disruptors,
we negate those that are
playing on different parts
of the chessboard.
I remember, again
from a corporate side,
I was a black student
union president,
and I'm raising
hell on my campus,
and we're addressing some
fundamental policy issues,
and I'm looking at my dad
who's in corporate America,
like, he a sellout.
He's just getting paid.
And he was a VP
of Human Resources
and head of Affirmative
Action at the University
of Cincinnati.
And I didn't
understand the stakes
until the University
of Cincinnati
got audited for federal
formative action
compliance for hiring.
They gave him falsified
numbers to sign off on.
He filed an obstruction
suit against them.
He got fired.
He was all of a
sudden incompetent.
And it was then that
I said, wait a minute.
When my dad was here,
more people of color
got hired than got hired
when he wasn't there.
There was better relationships
between labor and management
when he was there
helping negotiate
than when he wasn't there.
The people there
got greater benefits
when he was there than
when he wasn't there.
I was looking through
the lens of this really
aggressive, grassroots,
mobilization
model as the only model.
He was walking through the
shadows in corporate America,
ensuring that people's
lives were better.
And he still got caught as a
result of when the time came
to decide whether or not I'm
going to continue to play
this subversive
game, or whether I
have to stop them
in their tracks,
he decided to be the
ultimate disruptor.
And he paid the cost.
Six years later, his case got
kick backed from the US Supreme
Court to the Sixth
Circuit Court of Appeals,
where he had to take a
settlement, because the judge
hearing the case was an
alum of the university
and a former associate
of the firm representing
the university and
wouldn't recuse herself.
And so at some point, no matter
where you play disruptor,
you come up against
the realities
of the systematic
oppression that's real.
And so until,
regardless of where
we are on that chess
board, whether we're
chipping away at it by being
inside of these systems,
trying to do what we
can from the inside,
or we're outside
trying to push as hard
as we can to crack
them from the outside,
if we're not playing chess,
then at the end of the day,
we're risking people
on the outside that
are willing to be aggressive
without playing an inside game
that's more sophisticated.
ROLAND MARTIN: I mentioned
a couple of books earlier.
I'm very much a
reader, and as you
were talking about
disruptors, revolutionaries,
who might look different,
immediately came
to mind former staff writer
of the "Chicago Defender," who
John Sengstacke,
sends to Michigan,
takeover the "Michigan
Chronicle," Louis Martin.
The book is called "Walking
With Presidents-- Louis
Martin and the Rise of
Black Political Power,"
by Alex Poinsett.
And perfect example--
brother working
in the Kennedy administration,
Johnson administration.
Some folks said, man,
you selling out. .
And what he's doing is placing
folks in different positions,
advising the president,
literally affecting power.
Bob Brown accompanied Coretta
Scott King to the airport
to get Dr. King's body.
Nixon hires him in
the administration.
He had no designated portfolio,
but was doing exactly what
you were saying to folks there.
But how you work it with Nixon?
He's saying, but this is
what I'm doing inside.
So Dr. Stovall, getting
people to understand
that this idea of being a
revolutionary and a disruptor
looks totally
different depending
upon what the goal is--
is it important for folks
to have the conversations to get
a better sense of that person
as an individual
to go, oh, now, I
see what you're about, as
opposed to simply making
assumptions externally.
DAVID STOVALL: Real talking,
to be totally confessional
about this, I was the worst
in assuming things of folks,
in terms of their appearance.
So in terms of seeing someone,
I'm like, man, that chump.
I'll rock him the face.
Man, come on, man.
He playing with me, right?
And what I really
didn't understand
was actually, folks who
look like that actually
got me into grad school.
Real talk, right?
And I think the other
thing to understand--
and the point that
everybody made--
if you have made any type
of commitment to justice,
it is never if they are coming.
It is when they are coming.
So you have to be prepared
for when they come.
And I learned that
from folks who
may not have the same
type of disposition,
but also who are very clear
about how they understood
the justice condition,
because I think that there's
many ways for us to approach
what the justice condition is.
When you were talking, the
first person I thought about
was Ella Baker.
Ella Baker was very clear.
ROLAND MARTIN: One of the
greatest unknown organizers
in history.
DAVID STOVALL: And
what did she say?
We are the ones we
have been waiting for.
So what does it mean to
actually move in that light,
because the thing is always
now-- and I love Dead Prez.
Used to say this
all the time-- I
don't care what you come to
the revolution looking like.
I just want you to
come to the revolution.
You could bespoked up.
You could have it fried,
dyed, laid to the side.
You could have a bunch of locks.
You would have a fro as big
as the one me and my pops
used to rock.
That doesn't even
matter, as long
as you are there, and as long
as you are determining what
is that justice as condition.
Because if we are able to agree
on that justice condition,
we can now figure
out the numerous ways
to move to make sure
that it happens.
ROLAND MARTIN: I know you all
are going to get tired of this.
But I have this book too,
which is phenomenal--
"Ella Baker and the Black
Freedom Movement-- a Radical
Democratic Vision"
by Barbara Ransby.
DAVID STOVALL:
Right up the street.
ROLAND MARTIN: To understand
Ella Baker continuum--
progressive politics in the
'40s, NAACP field secretary,
is SCLC creator, SNCC creatot--
that's a continuum there
all throughout.
We're going to go to questions.
All right, we got microphone.
Come on up.
AUDIENCE: So Dr. Stovall--
ROLAND MARTIN: You've
been taking notes, I see.
AUDIENCE: I have
been You mentioned
a definition of white
supremacy that I've never
heard anyone articulate
in such an important way,
and I think it's
really interesting.
How do we support--
all of us-- how
do we support what we're trying
to do here without raising
the ire of that particular
group of people that are now
out there supporting
people like Donald Trump?
What's the balance, and
I think it goes back
to your last point
of god, I'd like
to find a way to do
this without alienating
and sort of bringing out
the worst of the people who
feel intimidated now by those
of us who want to change.
DAVID STOVALL: Well, I think
this is the thing right.
And thank you for that question.
I don't think that
should be our job.
And I don't think that we can.
Because I think
the misconception
is that we want to win
people over to our side.
That's not it.
The thing is we want to
recognize what this thing is.
We can disagree about it, but
I want folks to understand
how this affects folks.
What does it mean
in the day-today,
because this thing-- you can
argue all day with someone
about their particular
disposition,
but it's really this thing
around if you have made
a conscious decision to
the justice condition,
you have already become
confrontational before you've
even had the conversation.
I mean it's one of those things.
I mean, it's not about
being appeasing to folks.
I mean, I think that's
the mistake we make.
It's not about being
friendly enough.
It's like, look, this
is happening now.
If we're really about
where we stand on things--
and this is another thing,
once people reveal themselves,
now you know how to move,
because once that person shows
up, you say, OK,
that's that one.
I need to go elsewhere.
Here's the work,
because what we want
to do, in this larger
justice condition,
we want those folks to
show their ugly head.
Now we know we're
dealing with right.
It's harder with that
person smiles and now does
the little passive
aggressive thing,
and now the door is
closing, and they
got two AK-47s waiting for you.
So in Chicago, we used
to crack this joke.
When you go to a
meeting with anybody
in the city of Chicago, the
mayor's office or whoever,
you have to understand that
there's a .38 on the table.
As soon as you turn your back,
someone's brains is blown out.
Walk backwards once
you leave the table.
And that sounds extreme, but
this thing around when we get
caught into that idea
around conversion,
we obfuscate what
we're trying to do,
which is to identify
how this affects folks
and then what this justice
condition is, and now, how
we are committed to pursue it.
Because I believe that all
those folks will now start--
we always like to use
this term-- self-select
and go elsewhere.
ROLAND MARTIN: We also
make the mistake, I think,
of trying to make
everybody comfortable,
when the reality is this
is all uncomfortable.
STEVE PERRY: At it's
core, it's disruptive.
I mean, the expectation is
that the only way we will truly
become the country
who we set out to be
or the person that you set out
to be is to change your habits.
The only way you're
going to lose weight
is to change the way
you eat, increase
your cardio, whatever it is.
Change is by design disruptive.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Well, first of all,
you've got to acknowledge
that you want to change.
STEVE PERRY: Well, there's that.
But once you've done that,
once you've called for change,
you have to do so.
For instance, in
hiring, you have
to look beyond the circumstances
that you typically look beyond.
You have to look for
different skill sets.
You have to be willing to
open your mind and heart
through the fact that somebody
may look at the problem
differently.
And so they may
not be an answer.
There may be multiple answers,
and as a result of which,
you become disruptive
to the hiring practice,
thereby creating an
entirely new conversation
within your organization.
And so it's not just
about-- one of the problems
I have, for instance,
with the Democratic Party
is this notion of diversity.
Yeah, the colors were different.
But they all got
up there and said
some version of the same thing.
So I didn't really
see diversity.
I saw a different colored people
and some different genders,
of course.
But at the end of the day,
there wasn't true diversity.
And so in order for us
to have the conversation
around disruption, we have to
be comfortable with the idea
that this disruption
is going to be
at its core uncomfortable
for a spell.
ROLAND MARTIN: It's
funny you said that,
because Oprah Winfrey is on
the cover of the "Hollywood
Reporter" Ava
DuVernay this week. .
And Oprah says she has removed
diversity from her vocabulary
because Ava has taught
her, no, forget diversity.
We want inclusion.
You want to be at the table.
She said, not just diverse--
it's about inclusion.
STEVE PERRY: And at the table
in a position where your voice
matters as much
as anyone else's.
There are times in which
I've been part of movements
where they call me after
a decision has been
made that we're having a march.
And I'm like, what the hell?
If I'm part of this,
shouldn't I been
communicated with when you
were considering the action?
Shouldn't my opinion
have mattered as much?
See, inclusion in
that sense, is when
my voice matters
as much as anyone
else's in the conversation.
And until such time as my voice
is seen-- at the start of this,
I acknowledged that we don't
have a lot of women up here,
because I think it's
important that it be clear
that I recognize that, that
I'm not OK with the fact
that from a parity perspective
I'm calling and saying,
what we need to do as
people, and I'm calling
upon other people,
but on the same token
not acknowledging
my own conversation,
that we in this stage, if
nothing else, in diversity
of thought, would have
a diversity agenda here.
ROLAND MARTIN: Let's
go to questions.
Of course, folks
who are watching,
you can also ask questions.
So it's Ana Turner.
How can corporations best
participate in racial justice
without undermining
existing social movements?
Who wants that?
DAVID STOVALL: There is
a great science educator
by the name of
Jomo Mutegi, who's
at the University of
Indiana Indianapolis.
ROLAND MARTIN: You're going to
have to spell that one later.
DAVID STOVALL: Yeah.
And Jomo always
makes this point.
He says, here's what you can do.
He says, first,
you can apologize.
Second, do not start to join or
make claims about a commitment
to anything that you are
not willing to support.
Third, get out of the way.
So it's always
these things around,
because a lot of times-- this
is a thing in education we often
talk about this.
The word help is temporary.
We're talking about
solidarity, which
is a very different thing.
It is a more contested word.
It means something different.
It means that you
have agreed to support
something that will challenge
you in the support of it.
So now I think that
becomes important,
because I hate it when I hear
folks say, I just want to help.
We don't need that.
I want to be clear about
that, because all that is
is temporary, and all
that is a feel good thing.
What we want folks
to do is to be
able to challenge their
existence in this.
We got to ask a different
set of questions,
because I might even depart
at a different space,
because when we look at the
language of this country,
we see something
different, not just
in the Emancipation
Proclamation,
not just in the Constitution.
We need to read stuff like
the Federalist Papers,
particularly.
Like Federalist Papers--
as [INAUDIBLE] talks
about-- Federalist
Papers 2, 10, and 22,
that talks about
the United States
as being a country
in and of its space
being preserved for white men.
So now we begin to
ask those questions.
It's not about us helping.
It's how are we willing
to challenge ourselves
in a very particular
way and then get out
of the way to let folks
who have committed
to do this work do this work.
ROLAND MARTIN: And first, about
what you're laying out, also,
about understanding that
you're understanding
how the nation was
constructed, which
means that you're understanding
the DNA of America.
So when you actually
go through all of that,
you can actually tie the
Federalist Papers to 2016.
I just got an email-- and
he said it on Saturday
when I was with him, Virginia
governor Terry McAuliffe,
when he restored the
voting rights of 13,000
formerly incarcerated.
What folks don't realize is
the law that prevented them
from voting was literally
based upon a legislator or 1902
who said, this is to
keep darkies from voting.
And he said, I'm
restoring these rights,
because the law was based
on a racist premise. .
But folks, in 2016, we're still
fighting to uphold that law
but had no idea-- they
claim-- of the history.
Carmen.
CARMEN PEREZ:
There's also what's
called Solidarity Summit.
There's about 40 of us that
travel across the country with
OSI-- Open Society Institute--
and the Ford Foundation,
and we actually do some
really deep digging around
our personal cultures and
do cultural exchanges. .
And I think that's
also important to do.
And when you look
at-- one of the things
that I know in any institution
is usually I'm the only Latina.
I'm the only woman.
Or I'm younger than
everybody by 10 or 20 years.
And so I will say that one of
the things that I've learned
is that people will say, well,
it's because people of color
aren't qualified.
We don't have qualified
people, so that we could
hire them to do this work.
And I think that needs to shift.
You were talking about not
just diversity in color,
but also diversity in
age, diversity in gender,
in different levels.
But it's not just about
being at the table.
It's the fact that when
you're creating something,
bring those that are impacted
or those that you're actually
looking to serve to actually
be a part of that conversation,
like you were saying.
But I know for me, one of the
things I constantly look at
is am I taking up
too much space?
Especially being a Latina in
a Black Lives Matter movement,
or being an older person
working with youth,
am I taking up too much space?
And also, am I giving
individuals the opportunity
and also supporting and
cultivating their leadership,
right?
And it's also about
relationship building.
It's not about, like,
oh, you know what?
You know, I don't
have black friends,
so now I'm going to go
make some black friends
and ask them every
race question.
It's about you know
what, like I really
want to be intentional
about who I'm talking to
and who I'm building
relationships with.
Go ahead.
But I just kind of
want to offered that,
just because I also know there
are white people that do this
work around Black Lives Matter,
and there are white allies. .
And sometimes they
take up a lot of space.
They're the ones that are
showing up to the protest.
They're the ones that
are doing the chants.
And sometimes you gotta
remind them of their space.
And I sometimes don't want
to remind all white people
of where they need to be.
What I will say is that
they'll be out there fighting
for the liberation
of black people,
but when you go to their dinner
table, ain't nobody black.
So I just kind of want
to point that out.
JEFF JOHNSON: Real
quick, Roland,
because I think that
there are a couple things.
One is I think companies
have the ability
to do two really easy
things-- well, not easy,
but pragmatic things.
One is create ecosystems of
conversation that traditionally
didn't happen before.
And so how do you
create ecosystems
versus echo chambers?
So often within
institutions, people are just
shouting at each other.
Sometimes they're shouting
at each other in silence.
So when two black men get shot
by police and police officers
get shot, people may not
be shouting at each other,
but they're shouting
at each other.
So I know what side you're on.
And we're walking by each
other in the hallway at work.
And we ain't saying nothing.
But I know you
support them cops,
or I know you support
them black folks.
And we're shouting at each
other, but nobody's listening.
And so how can you be courageous
enough as a corporation
to create ecosystems where
it's not about whether it's
Blue Lives or Black Lives.
It's how do we create
ecosystems in our firms
that create space to have
difficult dialogue that
doesn't become
judgemental or combative.
And isn't about walking
away with agreement,
because I think so often
these conversations are
about do we walk away agreeing
versus do we walk away
better understanding?
The second thing is
how do we support
the individual passions of our
employees without repercussion?
And so as long as I'm
engaged in something
that's not breaking
the law, can my company
support me doing that?
Third, how do we have
better conversations
about the ecosystem of impact,
because, to Carmen's point,
it's not necessarily
about Google
showing up with Google shirts
at the Black Lives Matter rally.
It's about where is
there an economic impact
of a certain demographic of
customers of our corporations,
and how do we engage them
in conversation or support
in ways that are beyond
showing up at a rally?
Where's the economic impact?
And I think in the
movement, we don't always
have economic impact-based
conversations.
So where is the
social venture impact
opportunities for companies
to say, wait a minute.
I'm not going to be on the
front line of this movement.
But I am going to support the
development of new schools
that impact this community in
a way that reduces violence,
because more opportunity
less violence?
Or I am going to have
a conversation where
why can't companies begin--
I'm confused about why
in Chicago, there has not been
a public meeting of corporations
about what's the economic
impact of violence
to the city of Chicago,
where companies
begin to say, wait a minute.
We have a responsibility to
development of infrastructure
and support in a city.
I know I'm reaching.
But what I'm saying
is she asked what
were the potential solutions
of ways they can participate
in racial justice
without undermining
the existing social movement.
Play your role.
And your role is in the
impact of the economy.
And so how do you do that
by having conversations
with those that are impacted by
the economic impact of violence
in Chicago or lack of
education in Baltimore.
But I don't see those companies
feeling like they're invited
or feeling the responsibility to
lead those discussions to talk
about a whole another set
of ecosystem that impacts
racial and social
justice without getting
in the way of those
on the ground.
ROLAND MARTIN: My answer to
this question is very quick.
Before you decide
to get involved
in some external movement,
look inside your company first,
because it's just like my
biggest criticism of mainstream
media.
Mainstream media can't call
out the Republican Party
when it comes to outreach
of black folks, when they
don't outreach to black folks.
And so it's very hard for
you to say, oh, no, no, no,
we support that.
But then when you look inward,
you go, oh, wait a minute.
So when Reverend Jackson
targeted Silicon Valley,
he said, you can't
have officials
of Silicon Valley
writing checks that's
supporting organizations, to
your point, wearing the shirts,
but employing less than
1% of certain groups,
and not just in science and
technology, when the reality is
60% of all Silicon Valley jobs
don't even involve technology.
It's your accounting firms,
law firms, advertiser firms,
marketing firms.
So any company, look at yourself
first before you go outside,
because you might
get called out.
Question here,
question here, then I'm
going to another question
from an external audience.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
One of the things that I heard
that profoundly affected me
from Tim Wise was that white
privilege is not about guilt,
that white privilege is
about responsibility.
And I think it's
tangentially related
to what you were just talking
about-- that responsibility
that we have.
I'd love to hear your
thoughts about guilt
versus responsibility
and that notion of trying
to be comfortable, and
it's not possible really
to be comfortable,
that we really
need to be uncomfortable to
be able to be responsible.
And that's not for our
own personal actions,
but for what has happened in the
country and around the world.
I'd love to hear your thoughts.
ROLAND MARTIN: Two
folks-- tight answers
in follow-up to that question.
DAVID STOVALL: Super quick-- one
of the ways to actually engage
that question is what
Brother Martin first said. .
The conversation is far
with other white folks.
Clearly this thing
around when you
are engaging with other white
folks about what this actually
means, then you get another
set of conversations.
So in addition to
Tim Wise, check out
a guy named Paul Gorski.
He's committed to
doing this work.
And then what he talks about
is that type of conversation
is the in-house conversation
that other folks might not
be privy to, But now will allow
you to think about how you move
and what you do moving forward,
because a lot of times it's not
about going into the guilt
mode around making folks
feel halfway decent
that you now recognize
what's happened to them.
It's really around what
do we say to each other,
recognizing this
thing to be true.
ROLAND MARTIN: Another
person you mentioned--
say the name again. .
DAVID STOVALL: Paul Gorski.
ROLAND MARTIN: Another person
you should YouTube is-- I'm
trying to pull up her
name-- Jane Elliott.
CARMEN PEREZ: Yes.
Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: She did
this blue eye experiment
on the Oprah show that
totally-- go look at her videos.
And she goes right to
the heart of this issue.
And she asks this question
of an all-white audience,
how many of you
would trade places
with a rich black person?
And nobody raised their hand.
She says that's white
privilege right there.
And y'all ain't rich.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
guys for coming.
This is really important.
One of the biggest questions
that I have is what can I do?
What should I do that
demonstrates solidarity not
help, that is in the right
lane, that acknowledges
that I am a white person, but
I still want to help with this?
STEVE PERRY: Thank
you for your question,
and I was waiting
for that question.
I think that you
have to first do
an assessment of your own
talents and interests.
As Brother Johnson
said a little earlier,
he talked about people
working in different spaces
and the respect that we
have to have for that.
And so whatever it
is that you think
you could have an impact on
using your time and talents
to make that happen.
So for instance, if you
feel like your work was
best with women, because
you're a woman, and for me,
it would be about finding
an organization that looked
to improve the lives of women.
If it was about
writing about women,
then you'd use your written
word to push that forward.
I think any person that tells
everyone that they should do
something in particular is
a person who's not learned
and not compassionate and
doesn't understand that
there's a beauty in the
intricacy of each one
of our gifts. .
And so I think what
we're tasked with
is engaging your heart such
that your mind will follow
and that you will use your
mind to think of the things
that you could do.
One of things I often think that
we all have an obligation to do
is to involve
ourselves in what I
refer to as
micro-political actions,
meaning individual
tasks that will somehow
improve the lot of
those people around you.
And that may be something
as simple as volunteering
on a school board
or working-- again,
from my space-- with
children, to recognizing
that at your
company there may be
an affinity group, an
African-American group,
or a Latino group, or
a gay straight alliance
group, whatever the case
may be within the context
of your company,
wherever you feel
you could make the greatest
impact using your time
and talents to do something.
Other people are not
going to get caught up in,
let's say, something that
is political and a big P
political.
Whereas, some people
may say, I don't
want you to think that
because you did something
at Google that that would
somehow be less than important.
I would suggest to you that
there's a lot that you can do.
It starts with you taking
an inventory, doing
an audit of your time,
talents, and desires,
and with all due haste,
not waiting another day,
because I'll say this final
thing-- the fact that you
guys are here is dope.
And I say that
sincerely because I'm
sure that they're going
to pay you no matter
where you are in the building.
But based upon the food that was
coming out of a sick cafeteria
that you seem to have, y'all
could have spent a little more
time there.
The fact that you're
here leads me to believe
that you want to do something.
You want to be inspired.
You want to find the
space in which you fit in.
And the challenge that I
know that I have at times
is, I want to answer your
question like in the way
that I think you want it
answered, like a specific,
you should tomorrow
morning go here.
But I don't know
the answer to that.
But I do know tonight,
on your ride home,
you can come up with a
solution, because that thing
that's been peeing
inside your heart
that you should do--
not should anymore.
It's must.
ROLAND MARTIN: Jeff.
JEFF JOHNSON: Real quick.
The other thing I
would say is listen,
because I think a lot
of us in our desire
to do good bring too many
assumptions to that process.
I'll never forget taking a
bunch of college students
to New Orleans
right after Katrina.
And they were
incredibly well-meaning,
but unbelievably arrogant.
They thought they were saving
somebody on their spring break.
And we had to tell them
before they engaged,
the most important thing
you can do tomorrow
is listen to what the
people tell you to do,
because they already
have the answers.
And if you are going to be
in solidarity with them,
it's not about you coming
in with your brilliance
to tell them what they need.
It's your humility coupled
with your brilliance that can
be directed in the right way.
ROLAND MARTIN: When we mentioned
the Barbara Ransby book
on Ella Baker, that
was the one thing
she told everyone at the
NAACP, SCLC, and the SNCC.
She said, when
you go to Alabama,
and you're going to those
sharecroppers, first of all,
take off your damn college
clothes and put a overall on.
And she said, and
listen to them.
Forget the fact
that some of them
have a third and
fourth grade education.
She said, let them tell you what
they want to do and then say,
I'm here to help
you achieve that.
So that was one of her
biggest piece right there.
Listen to what
they want to hear.
Dory, you got something for me?
All right, I'm going to
go to a question here.
Let's go.
AUDIENCE: Hey,
how are you doing?
Thank you so much for coming.
Being nine years here at
Google, having something
like this occur is
really, really awesome.
A lot of us talk about
it on the sidelines,
but it's great to have
a premiere event here.
And thank you for hosting and--
ROLAND MARTIN: Glad to be here.
AUDIENCE: And others,
[INAUDIBLE] for being here.
I want to provide two
things that may be more
for the fellow Googlers.
One thing you can
do is definitely
hook up with some of the ERGs.
The ERGs are all open.
ROLAND MARTIN: OK,
I ain't from here.
What the hell is an ERG?
AUDIENCE: Employee
resource groups,
So Hola for Latinos, BGN.
It's not exclusive to just
Latinos or just blacks.
The diversity book
club is reading
"Between the World and Me."
We're going to meet
on that next week.
Women Aat, Gayglers, et
cetera-- more than just
going to the pride
party, actually talking
about the issues.
And then sometimes I known to
be a little disruptive, so what
I would like to challenge
to my fellow Googlers
and Googler leadership
is we have cases
where the mayor of Chicago
has graced our stage,
where Kissinger has
graced our stage
in Mountain View, et cetera.
But let's also bring over
the other side of things.
Let's bring the CTU
leadership to discuss
why they think they
might have to go
on strike in a couple
of weeks, because they
value how they interpret--
maybe we don't all
agree-- what they value
in terms of what families
and children in Chicago need.
How many of us live
in Chicago and feel
so mixed about the
schools and how they're
addressing that, et cetera?
So let's hear some
of those viewpoints
instead of just always having
the mayor and everyone we
have to have good
relationships, but we
have some other viewpoints.
So let's challenge ourselves
to hear some of those.
Same thing on other issues.
There's gay groups.
There's women's groups,
et cetera groups,
that all have great
speakers, great partnerships
and let's put them
out there, not just
the mayor or the political
leadership, which might all
kind of reflect one way.
Let's hear out some of
the other viewpoints.
ROLAND MARTIN: But also
I will say this here.
Challenge groups about
what happens internally.
The reason I say that, three
months ago, Michael Sam
gave an interview with
a British magazine,
and he said he faced more
racism from white LGBTers
than he did black homophobia.
It got virtually no coverage.
I had a whole panel
of African-Americans
who were gay and lesbian, and
we talked about that very issue.
And I posed the
question, how could you
have an equality movement
where you practice inequality?
And I guarantee
you had Michael Sam
said he faced a plethora
of black homophobia
and love from white LGBT, CNN,
MSNBC, Fox News, ABC, CBS, NBC,
would have all had panels, think
pieces in the "New York Times"
on black homophobia.
And again, that's one
of those discussions
one can have among groups.
The issue of colorism,
also, with African-Americans
another major issue.
STEVE PERRY: Before
you go forward,
I was laughing to myself
as the gentlemen was
talking about having
different groups here.
One of things I
would encourage you
also is have the other side.
If you all are going
to have CTU here,
I'm not saying you
call me, although--
ROLAND MARTIN: Steve's
saying call Steve.
STEVE PERRY: --although I will
come back in an ambulance.
ROLAND MARTIN: Steve
would drive here.
STEVE PERRY: Damn right.
But for real.
The important point is to
have a valid and meaningful
counterpoint to some
of those conversations,
because one of things
that happened sometimes
is if you're not familiar with
the topic, the person who's
presenting the topic whose
job it is to present the topic
and always make it seem
like it makes more sense.
I want to use that
just really quick.
So for instance,
let's say you were
to bring in the conversation
around the Chicago Teachers
Union saying they're
going to strike again.
I would suggest you also
bring in some parents,
some other individuals
who are going
to be hurt badly when
such a decision is made,
and on through, not
just the usual suspects,
But individuals who are
impacted by whatever
the conversation is.
So that what you end up doing is
creating a robust conversation
from which individuals
who are being introduced
to the topic for the
first time, could actually
have the opportunity
to hear, wait a minute.
I never really thought
of it that way,
regardless of what the topic is.
You see a diversity
of thought up here.
We haven't spent
enough time that you
would see the breadth
of the diversity,
but I think you've
heard it in just
some of the slight conversation
that you've heard that there's
a diversity of thought here.
And I don't know the others as
well as I know Jeff and Roland.
If the three of
us were in a, room
you'd hear the diversity
really quickly.
ROLAND MARTIN: And real loud.
STEVE PERRY: Right.
JEFF JOHNSON: From them two.
ROLAND MARTIN: Yeah, like
you have never got loud.
OK, all right.
STEVE PERRY: What
you'd hear from Roland
would be the loudness
of his pocket square.
CARMEN PEREZ: I also want to
add I really love the panel
conversation and having a host.
But there is a model called the
world cafe, where you actually
do panel conversations,
and then you
break out into
smaller conversations,
and then bring it
back to the room.
And when I talk about
relationship-building,
one of the things-- you
said it perfectly-- I
always tell people, don't go
start other organizations.
Tap into what you do
really well and offer that
to an organization
that's around you,
because you could teach
somebody a discipline.
You can't teach
them to have heart.
And you want people who have
heart to come and volunteer
for you or offer you.
But also you could donate to
organizations, keeping it $1.
There are organizations that
also need financial resources,
but like I said, you know, I
think it's really important
to also build relationships
among yourselves,
because you guys all have
to work with one another. .
ROLAND MARTIN: I got
less than two minutes.
Question right here.
Go right ahead.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Dr. Perry,
I'm going to give you
a little bit of an opportunity,
because my question was
for you, a lot of what
our Chicago office does
the most of is around
education out on the community.
So what are some of the things
that you see specifically
within the institutions?
What are the main
changes you would
like to see that have the
biggest impact quickly?
STEVE PERRY: Thank you the
most important thing for me
is school choice.
Allow the parents to make those
micro-political decisions.
This is still a democracy.
A parent should not be
forced to send their child
to a school in which
the people working it
would never send their
children to Start there.
The second thing is recognize
that the conversation
around education in the
United States of America
is driven by employment,
not education.
That's why these are essentially
are boards of employment,
not boards of education.
The system is designed to
ensure that individuals
who work in it stay employed.
There's a shift in the
paradigm of professionalism.
Unlike generations
from the past, where
this generation of
professionals do not necessarily
value job security.
You value the product.
And that doesn't happen in the
traditional public education
system at the level it should.
In fact, it's longevity that
gets you the greatest reward,
as opposed to productivity.
And so you have to
take the same model
that you use here, that is
in, fact working, not just
here but Uber and Airbnb,
where you're seeing
a product that's meaningful.
So you, as consumers,
whether or not you
have children in the system,
you are in fact consumers
because at the end of the
day, to Brother Jeff's point,
you're going to
either employ or not
employ Chicago Public
Schools; graduates.
So there needs to be a
push from organizations
such as this to push
for the very things
that you want for
your own children,
were you to have them,
if you have them,
and that is to have access
to a quality education.
I ask you to ask for nothing
more and nothing less.
To what Brother
Stovall was saying,
sometimes the conversation
is about equity.
And freedom means that some
people need a little bit more
in order to get equal,
because for so long,
they have not gotten that.
So for me, the bottom line
is if this school is so good,
then no child should ever have
to be forced to attend it.
They will attend it
because they wish to.
School choice provides families
with the same opportunity that
has been provided to the wealthy
and white Americans forever,
because for the first
time in American history,
we're actually having a
conversation about poor people
who are saying, where are you
sending your child to school
this year?
That was a conversation that for
generations was confined only
to the well-to-do.
So I'm saying, with all due
haste, push as hard as you can
for school choice, school
choice, school choice,
because that is the only
strategy that will provide
for access to a
quality education
within the lifetime
of the children who
are, in fact, in school.
ROLAND MARTIN: I will
give you another book.
This is probably one of
the most important books
I have ever read.
You will be blown away
by the first 50 pages.
"The Education of Blacks
in the South, 1860-1935"
bu James A. Anderson,
a professor right
here in Illinois--
University of Illinois.
Took him 10 years
to do that book.
And he lays out
that not only that--
the first collective bargaining
was freed slaves, where
after slavery, plantation owners
wanted them to work the land,
and they said, we will only
agree to work the land,
if you build a school
on the grounds.
That was collective
bargaining. .
Go ahead, Doctor.
DAVID STOVALL:
Just something real
quick around this
thing around it.
We made depart on
this moment, but I
want us to be clear about
when we talk about education,
there is an assumption
that is very dangerous.
One of the assumptions
that is very dangerous
is that education works like
you all do in businesses.
And this is why it's dangerous.
Models of efficiency tell us
that we can do a lot of things
very well and sanguine.
We don't learn like that.
So education can be effective,
but it's not always efficient
in the general
sense of efficiency.
And I think there's a common
assumption or misconception
that if something is working
smoothly, that it's working.
That is not the case.
We have to have spaces
that support young folks
in the ways in which
they learn, because this
is a big contention,
because a lot of times folks
can drop in communities and
say, here's this new thing.
And you've had a ton of shit.
And here's this new thing.
But all it really is new. .
They haven't talked about
what this thing is actually
putting forward.
So a lot of times you get these
situations where families,
their desperation is played
on, and opposed to saying,
here's what we're going to
do in partnership with you,
it's opposed to you've had shit.
Here's this new thing.
I don't know.
It's at least not that
thing that you've had.
And I think that thing
becomes critically important
when we talk about
educational spaces,
because that piece
around being affective
based on the community's
needs is critical.
Anything else is a projection
of the larger colonial project.
STEVE PERRY: I think
one of the things,
also, to keep in mind as we
have that conversation is
that the reason why parents
are running screaming
from these schools is
because in many cases
they went to those
schools as well.
And their grandparents
went to those schools.
And they were
under-served by them.
And so no one should
consider opening anything,
whether it be any
type of organization
in a community that doesn't
take into consideration
the integrity of the community.
On the same token, no one
should also stop the parents
from doing what
they must do to go
to the best schools they can.
There are children who have
attended my schools who
I know for a fact do not
live in the catchment areas.
I know it.
I know they're using
somebody else's address,
and I will never tell.
It is not going to happen,
because I'd rather them break
a law that is unjust than to do
something as unjust as to put
abide by the law.
We have a set of laws that have
been put in place that started
with the various segregation
of neighborhoods,
the creation of ghettos,
that have fostered
the failures of
millions, literally
millions, of children-- millions
who've done nothing wrong other
than to be born in
the wrong zip code.
And so what we hear too
often in the conversation
around education is
about employment.
We do not hear
about the children.
And you you'll hear diversionary
tactics about testing
and privatization and other
notions that somehow are meant
to take your eye off the ball.
But at the end of the
day, if you are so blessed
to be a parent, you will
pray the same prayer
over your children that every
single person has prayed
regardless of religion or type--
that your child does better
than you.
And one of the most important
things that you will do
is to decide on the school
that they will attend.
And we have seen these schools
fail-- great, fantastic,
amazing, teachers
in some of them,
fantastic principals
in some of them.
But for whatever the case
may be, they're not winning.
And I, for one, would never want
to be even slightly responsible
for keeping in place
any policies that
will send one child one
day to a failed school.
I'll say this final point.
Of the hardest things to see--
and anybody up who's ever
seen this knows this--
is the see a child who's
given up on school,
the dead stare
that comes over the face of a
seventh grader who recognizes
that there's just no hope for
her or him in this institution,
and that they have
in fact essentially
been broken-- intentionally
broken, so much so
that their self-esteem is shot,
versus the time when you see
the child who's four
or five years old
who's super-duper excited
about school, just
can't wait to come
to school and learn.
Why is it that we would ever
keep in place an institution
that has promised to destroy
the children most in need--
black, Latino, poor, more
specifically, African-American
boys?
Why would we ever send
another human being to that
and call ourselves
a humane society?
It's not about resources.
It's not about how
much a school costs,
because we spend the most
amount of resources locking
those very same little boys up.
The issue is about the quality
of the institution, which
starts with a respect for
the community, no doubt,
but also the anticipation
that every single child who's
in the building is
fricken amazing,
and they're going
to do everything
they can to make that possible.
CARMEN PEREZ: I just wanted
to add a cost analysis to what
he was saying, in regards--
ROLAND MARTIN: This is going
to be your final comment.
CARMEN PEREZ: Yeah, sorry.
It cost $125,000
in New York state
to lock a young person up per
year, versus $10,000 from K
to 12 to educate them.
So I just wanted to-- because
what he's talking about
is providing education
opportunities for young people
so that they could thrive
and not end up in the system
that I'm working in and seen
those young people at my table.
And so we see young people--
as young as 10 years old--
incarcerated in a
detention center.
And the clothes
doesn't even fit them.
And it's because they
don't have anything else.
They don't have hope anymore.
DAVID STOVALL: And
let us not forget
the rising number of
young girls of color who
are in those institutes--
STEVE PERRY: It's frightening.
DAVID STOVAL: It's critical,
because that population
has actually increased
300% since 1970.
STEVE PERRY: It's not
slowing down at all.
CARMEN PEREZ: 500.
DAVID STOVALL: So we have
to put that on the table.
ROLAND MARTIN: That's
your final comment?
DAVID STOVALL: Yes, sir
ROLAND MARTIN: Jeff Johnson,
you can close us out.
JEFF JOHNSON: Great book--
"Why Should White Guys Have
All the Fun?" by Reginald
F. Lewis, first person
to negotiate a billion dollar
deal in corporate America,
and speaks a lot about what
we've been talking about today.
Second of all, I
don't want to leave
without-- there's a
question up here that
says is it possible that women
are under-represented here
because the language
of disruption
and maybe the movement
isn't inclusive?
There was discussion about
mid-level, mid-tier corporate
jobs for black men
being emasculating,
but where do black women
fit into that conversation?
Simple answer is yes.
And I think Carmen and
others, many in this room,
have been fighting feverishly
to make sure that we challenge,
I think, some of the sexism
and misogyny that existed
within civil rights and
the black power movements
from a people of
color perspective,
but broadly as it relates to
movements for social change.
And we're constantly
challenging it.
And even us bringing
it up in the beginning,
saying, why is there only
one sister on the panel,
is part of it.
But the other piece
is, how are we
building pipelines of leadership
and voices of sisters,
especially within the movement,
where we don't immediately
go to the brother who
is on TV the most,
versus the sister who's
doing the better work?
So I think that's part of it.
Last but not least, I think that
one of the biggest challenges
with our discussions around
diversity and inclusion
from a corporate perspective
is even saying inclusion
is the goal isn't big enough.
The goal is community,
because if you
have diversity and inclusion,
that just means that you're
diverse enough to
check off boxes
and inclusionary enough to
invite people to the table,
but not deliberate
enough to make sure
that those people at the table
feel like they're represented
in all facets of the
DNA of the institutions
that we're a part of.
And only then do we
really have community.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Couple of points--
you don't have to
be of the same tribe
to help elevate somebody else.
Carmen knows this, because I've
actually told her and Linda
and Tamika that I will use
my platform to elevate y'all.
Not that I am against
some of the other people,
but I'm in control of my stuff.
And I get to pick who
I want to elevate,
and I'm recognizing--
to Jeff's point-- who's
actually doing the work.
Some folks they're hype.
Some folks actually do the work.
And so that's important, because
even in corporate America
you will talk to some
African-Americans, Latinos,
Asians who will tell you
there was somebody white
who was their best benefactor,
who supported them just
because.
You will find somebody black who
will say it was another sister,
and it was a brother
who was being elevated.
And so we look at the
individual and begin to say,
you know, I'm going
to invest in you,
because I think you
can do something.
The last point is there here.
Y'all are a part of a company--
folks in the room and also
those who are watching-- that
have been revolutionaries,
that have been disruptors, that
have literally changed multiple
industries over the
last 10 years. .
And the thing that
I think we have
to think when we look at, what
can we do-- because people
always say what can we do, and I
always use this example-- there
literally are more people
sitting in this room
right now than there
were sitting in a church
basement in Montgomery in 1955.
The Montgomery bus boycott we
know historically was 381 days.
It was never designed
to be a 381-day boycott.
It was actually a
one-day boycott.
And 50,000 black folks
didn't get on the bus,
and they went, hell, we
can go for two, then three.
And actually, if you look at
the original list of demands,
originally they didn't
even call for an end
to segregated busing.
They just asked for better
respect to black bus riders.
Can you hire a few
more black bus drivers?
Those were the initial demands.
Out of Montgomery
led the lawsuit,
Supreme Court ruling, then
they said, well, what else?
Then they went Albany, Georgia.
Then they were Selma
and Birmingham.
And then they went to cities all
across the South, four college
students, freshman.
Didn't ask anybody's permission
at North Carolina A&T,
they just chose to
say, we're going
to go integrate
this lunch counter.
That led to it spreading like
wildfire all across the South.
Imagine somebody sending a
tweet, and then all of a sudden
it literally goes across.
That's what that was.
The point I'm
making is this here,
that got us the Civil
Rights Act of '64,
Voting Rights Act of '65,
Fair Housing Act of '68.
That got us Arthur Fletcher
putting affirmative action
in place when Nixon
became president in 1969.
The point there is a handful
of people literally changed
the world.
If you go to Serbia,
there's an MLK drive.
There's one in India.
Lech Walesa, the solidarity
movement in Poland in 1980,
they were singing
"We Shall Overcome."
In Eastern Europe, they were
singing lift every voice
and sing.
The Arab Spring,
they were signs,
I am a man, which are the
exact same signs black man were
wearing in Memphis in 1968.
So the point there is a handful
of people in a church basement
literally has
impacted the world.
And so you might not think
it, but if you look around
in this room, you actually
have the capacity,
based upon a collective
action, based upon commitment,
based upon vision, based
upon being a disruptor,
to change the world, just
with the people sitting
in this room.
To Steve's point,
what are you prepared
to do when you leave this room?
Dr. Steve Perry, Carmen Perez,
Jeff Johnson, Dr. Stovall.
JEFF JOHNSON: Roland Martin.
ROLAND MARTIN: Round
of applause, please.
[APPLAUSE]